une séquence qui a beaucoup fait réagir
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux et
depuis quelques heures ça a été un
déferleront même toute cette nuit c'est
florian gazon l'humoriste qui était
samedi soir dans les grosses têtes et
qui a imité à yann nakamura lors
l'émission n'était pas en direct
et c'est vrai que ça s'est réveillée
deux jours après et il a mis voilà il
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ont parlé de rats sera sur le plateau de
grosses angoisses
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
insurgés contre voilà cette imitation
diana qu'à moi vous allez nous dire ce
que vous en pensez j'ai besoin de savoir
aussi vous aussi ce que vous en pensez
il ya même un comique kevin razy qu'on
connaît bien sur canal+ qui a réagi à ça
je vous dire ce qu'il a dit regarde
cette chanson de francis cabrel paca et
le bois comme avoir été
[Applaudissements]
il va sortir voilà alors voilà donc ça
nicolas lagrange et après ce que ça vous
choque dit la vérité je vous dis j'aime
bien en plus - florian voilà c'est un
mec que j'aime bien qu'il fût jamais
fait vraiment de débordements et c'est
vrai que là ça a pris des proportions
sur twitter énorme est-ce que vous
pensez que ça peu vexé des gens est ce
que vous pensez que c'est abusé parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens
qui ont dit vrai que c'est abusé il ya
kevin razy qui est vraiment un pote pour
le coup qui dit alors là il est grand
temps de dépoussiérer le pav de ces gens
décalage générationnel
parce que imiter yahia nakamura avec un
accent là michel leeb c'est pas possible
les frères je vois même pas la drôlerie
laissez-nous faire de l'humour
sincèrement nous c'est notre tapez vous
avez pris ce qu'il fallait prendre
pendant 30 ans maintenant faut nous
laisser manger et kevin hill a été je le
connais moi ça un pote et j'aimerais ce
mec et il a été il éthique blessés et
voilà donc on voit après est-ce que vous
pouvez comprendre et pas du tout et
jean-michel moi je suis désolé je m'aime
je me prenais une un sommaire sur la
gueule mais ça me choque pas terme euros
ça me choque ça soit pas drôle mais
qu'on a tous bluffés l'action qu'on fait
l'accent québécois ont fait l'accent
belge
et voilà on ponce nadal un des accès non
alors là juste assez grave dû fermer non
ça n'a rien à voir rien hors cadre
africain qui parle comme ça exerce des
métis non mais ça vous êtes complètement
déserte pas choquant c'est tous les
québécois ne parle pas non plus de
bernac une fois je suis pas d'accord et
qui n'osent il a raison sur un point
c'est que l'on a beaucoup vu ce genre
d'humour ou complètement ringard
maintenant c'est vrai que la référence à
michel leeb crise l accent africain on
est avec ceux qui avaient beaucoup de
talent et qui a beaucoup de talent enfin
ce genre d'humour là se maintenant c'est
terminé
moi j'aime beaucoup florian je les ai
connus quand même mieux inspiré après de
l'autre côté je trouve que tout le monde
est devenu très très susceptible mr que
ça prend des proportions dirait vraiment
c'est une agression au couteau
voilà donc des deux côtés je trouve
qu'on devrait un peu redescendre florian
revenir ça choque moi j'aimerais savoir
est ce qu'avec sa soeur couteau la table
ou pas du tout géraldine pas du tout on
n'a pas du tout et attention humour
communautaire parce que si à m sila
imite aya nakamura
il a droit c'est drôle alors il ne fait
pas comme ça il l'a fait il fermait pas
le même la mairie et à ce moment là ce
sera drôle ce sera ici parce qu'à metz
il a beaucoup de talent là c'est juste
pas drôle c'est ça qui est choquant je
reste flou
une question et limites j'aimerais avoir
l'avis de bouder qui est quand même le
seul humoriste autour de la table à la
preuve du contraire c'est ce problème
des vannes quand c'est pas drôle tout de
suite la sanction lna et pour le coup
brian a comme moi c'est une fille que
j'adore aussi il faudra qu est toujours
là vanessa mais parce qu'elle a du
succès vient elle parle pas comme ça ne
l'est pas du tout le français va laisser
pas ce cas là c'est parce qu'elle a du
succès tout simplement si c'est la prime
était une chanson c'est véridique
donc ça vous choque pas on va demander
aux gens sur twitter est ce qu'ils se
disent qu'ils ont concédé à choquer ou
pas valérie bénaïm voulu réagir
c'est juste parce qu'il faut aussi avoir
la réponse de florian gazan qui avait
répondu à kevin razy en disant qu'il n'a
pas vu la séquence en entier moi je n'ai
pas vu non plus un mais il dit tu n'as
pas vu les séquences en entier juste
avant on me demande et on faisait
shakira et donc j'ai fait shakira qui
fait rien nakamura est ce que voilà
c'est c'est en tout cas c'est ça des
fois la vie non mais une bonne façon à
blanchard il va faire regarder voir ce
qu'en pensent les téléspectateurs
choqués 7 84% voilà donc c'est vrai que
c'est un j'ai envie de dire c'est un
épiphénomène quoi